hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet in this little clip i'm
speaking to will store the author of the
book the status game which talks about
how we can understand motivation through
the lens of the social status games that
we all play every day i find this topic
incredibly fascinating and i think it's
so interesting how we all
have these like underlying motivations
for the things that we do like the
pursuit of money or career or wealth or
fame or like making youtube channels or
anything like that and it's interesting
just how much the desire for social
status is a fundamental part of
basically all of the things that we do
and that's the stuff that well and i are
talking about in this clip so yeah hope
you enjoy it okay let's talk about let's
talk about the status game how did you
come become interested in the topic of
the pursuit of social status well so the
heretics and then selfie and then the
science of storytelling those three
books were all about that idea of the
brain as a storyteller they were all
pursuing this one idea which is the
brain is
is this delusional machine which as i
said before remixes reality into this
heroic story we're in the middle of the
world the universe everything revolves
around us we're amazing you know as long
as we're psychologically healthy we have
all these you know creative artists so
i you know i started to think okay so if
that's
um if that's what's really going on if
that's the kind of delusion we're in the
middle of if that's the kind of lie of
the brain what's the truth of the brain
what's actually going on kind of beneath
the hood and um so this phrase that i
read um i think it was a psychology
school i think robert hogan came up with
this phrase that i i used in the selfie
and the science of storytelling that
that our you know our secret
subconscious drive is to get along and
get ahead and i thought that i always
loved that because it feels it's so
simple to understand
um yeah and the reason it's those things
is because we're tribal we're a tribal
animal we you know we're these apes that
have mastered the art of um um
cooperative living um uh you know we we
we we're driven to and and so so for
those reasons we have these very strong
subconscious urges to getting together
in groups of people who are like-minded
and um you know pursue goals with them
um but also
compete for status
with other members of that group but
also those groups compete for status
with rival groups and so that's tribal
life that's life in the tribe you know
um
that's why we organize the human life is
organized like that because it was
organized like that 20 000 years ago on
the african savannah
and you know i always find it's amazing
that that's still human life today you
know those groups are political groups
they're football teams they're um you
know cults their religions their
corporations that we
this is what we do that's human social
life it's groupish and it's complete
competition
and and so so the status game is is
really a book about that get along and
get ahead you know that's what a game is
a game is you get along you you clump
into a game of people that you're
playing a game with and then you you
start competing yeah how did the story
kind of come together did you start off
with the hypothesis that this is a thing
and then find the stories and the
examples and stuff to back it up or wait
was it more investigative like what was
the approach there yeah yeah
it was
so when i was researching selfie and
selfie is about um how the west west in
the west were very individualistic and
you know self-obsessed um relatively
speaking to the rest of the world and
and so it was looking kind of selfie
culture that narcissistic selfie culture
that's a great title by the way yeah it
wasn't my i can't take credit i remember
seeing it like i think in 2017 or
something yeah this one came out yeah
and i was like oh that's an interesting
book
yeah um yeah and um and i i interviewed
this guy called professor bruce heard
he's a very well-known psychologist down
at the university of bristol
and his put in my interview he said to
me oh you know he said why do we do the
things that we do so once we've got
enough money to
live and survive and we've got enough
money for our families to survive
is just about validation you didn't use
the word status use the word validation
you know that's why we write books
that's why we pursue that's why i'm a
scientist and yeah
and when he said that my immediate
response was oh come on that's so
cynical that's a ridiculous thing to say
and then i just sort of thought about it
for another like 30 seconds and i just
thought i think he's right yeah i think
he's right i really do think he's right
and that just really stayed with me and
then i just started researching it so i
started
doing looking at the science of kind of
status but then
what the light bulb moment for me was
really
the game part of it but because if you
just say it's all about status that's
half the story the other half is the
connection you know once you once we've
connected it's like connecting with
other people so so once they've started
to realize that um that um
[Music]
one of the light bulb moments for me was
was one of my ghost writing clients
actually
and he's a guy with a working-class
background he became very successful
and he's very very alpha male like you
know powerful um uh you know
military background like for some middle
class lower middle class like book geek
like me
quite intimidating and um you know when
i first met him it was a meeting at a
publishing company
i was a bit nervous to be with him
because i felt like
as far as he's concerned i'm this wimp
this little nerdy wimp you know with my
little cardigan on but i kind of felt he
was a bit nervous to meet me he was a
bit uncomfortable me and that really
made me sort of that's why what was
going on there and it was great because
he was really nice and i was expecting
him to be a bit
dismissive of me but he was so nice you
know and he was really enthusiastic to
understand and his whole thing with me
was just like mate i don't know what you
do but just do what you do yeah just
make this a great book and you know he
really trusted me yeah and um
and and that was the big breakthrough
for me because because i could because i
realized that we have different ways of
measuring status
like his way of measuring status is with
physical strength banter
probably football like talking about
football
um that's his criteria for claiming
status and that that's what he's proud
of you know his physicality yeah whereas
my criteria for claiming states are
things like books you've written and
getting nice reviews in the times or
you know
[ __ ] paintings on the walls all those
kinds of things and um
and
that's when i suddenly realized
we're not all competing with each other
we're playing different status games so
so when he came around my house to work
on my book and he saw the paintings on
the walls and all the books on the
shelves
even with the fact of his incredibly
masculine life
he probably would have felt a little bit
intimidated and a little bit
uncomfortable because he's in he's in a
different world now yeah and his
criteria for claiming status suddenly
doesn't count yeah and he you know um
and when i go into his world and and i'm
meeting with his very very masculine
terrifying you know people i'm like yeah
it's you know i mean everyone's really
nice so
you know but but that was the
breakthrough like we're playing
different status games and the thing to
understand is that is that we're not all
competing with each other we're all
playing little individual games and each
of these games has kind of symbolic
um ways of claiming status so you think
about monopoly the way you the way you
symbolize stages in monopoly is those
little plastic houses and hotels and the
money um
and that's how we play status games so
his symbolic
um
claims to status is his physicality his
history of extreme violence
um you know his success his huge
successes in that physical world um and
probably he's very proud of playing i
don't know if you could imagine football
or whatever those things are
and mine are completely different and
but but
and it was
and it was that understanding that
really made me see the world in a
different way to understand
the status games that we all play and
how
how
they drive us and make us kind of
different kinds of people yeah
yeah as i was listening to the audiobook
i found myself thinking that it is very
hard to get away from the fact from the
idea that
seeking status is bad
and that you know
similar to with the the stuff they talk
about in in the elephant in the brain
you know that that quote from allegedly
from jp morgan that a man always has two
reasons for doing something the good
reason and the real reason
and if i think of like what's my real
reason for being a youtuber for doing
this podcast when i'm wanting to write a
book it's like if i've got to be honest
with myself it isn't broadly status
motivated and i'm like [ __ ]
this is bad like shouldn't i have a more
like altruistic impact it's like yeah
it's kind of nice like teaching people
it's kind of fun talking to a camera but
but really
if i was doing it
if i was like talking to people and then
hitting delete rather than hitting
publish suddenly that changes the
equation and so okay what's going on
there
um yeah but what do you think about that
that like when
when i guess when we think or when we
point out the status thing it all feels
like a negative it does feel like a
negative a and that was the journey i
went on because it isn't i mean it can
be a negative there's lots of negative
in the book about the about the bad
sides of the status game but it's also
what's made civilization it's what is
what makes us good people
you know the history of the status game
again goes back to those tribes the
tribes in which we evolved and so you
know nature has to find a way of
incentivizing us to be valuable people
you know we
humans
can be very selfish and self-interested
and delusional and we know all those
things so how do you get
these creatures that have a tendency
towards selfishness to be selfless and
to work for the benefit of the tribe
where you incentivize them with status
and status is this reward so so what
happened was um you know we were playing
status games with our reputation we had
a reputation and try was you know um
and you'd get a good reputation you'd go
up in the status game if you proved
yourself to be valuable to the tribe and
there's two ways of being valuable to
the tribe you can be virtuous so you can
be generous courageous in battle a
follower of rules and an enforcer of
rules or you can be successful so um you
can be valuable to try by being a really
great honey finder a really great hunter
a really great storyteller a really
great sorcerer and so so
so so it's this reward that you get for
being valuable for being useful for
being kind and generous
and and so so that was true 10 000 years
ago is to still true today it's if you
think about like we're not used to uh
seeing people like gandhi and um
you know um malala as
superstars are celebrities but they are
you know that they are moral superstars
and that's good it's good that's that's
good that that's humanity at its best i
think is when we when we see valuable
people like
like gandhi or like um
the people who invented the astrazeneca
vaccine that you know um and we make
celebrities of them we're celebrating
them as we're making them heroic
and so you know without that we wouldn't
have civilization we wouldn't have the
moral world
as we know it because you know you can
feel it
with with the moral status thing when
you do something good and kind you feel
it in your body you go
you feel up you literally feel
physically up you know and when other
people find out they've done a nice
thing they go oh that's amazing yeah and
they and that's an automatic
response
and that's brilliant it's that's the
best of the human animal so so i do
think it's i i completely agree with you
that we are used to our condition to
seeing status as this negative thing and
it can be a very negative thing but it's
also the very very best of who we are as
a as a species
you know
in the book i talk about like things
like the origin of the iphone for
example
you know you know when steve jobs um
uh
kept meeting this guy from microsoft at
these parties because his wife was
friends with his wife
and this guy would be well we've solved
computing we're going to kill apple
we've got this new touch screen device
with a stylus
and um steve jobs was just livid because
because he was like hey you know he
didn't talk to me like that this
microsoft solved computing and he came
in and apparently there was a set of
expletives and he said right we're going
to show them how it's really done and
it's not a stylus with your finger make
the thing with the finger and they made
it and that was the iphone and then
again the ipad it started obviously yeah
so so you know that's a a great example
of
somebody very steve jobs very interested
in status unusually you know obsessed
with status
um and you know the iphone for good for
better or worse has changed the world
and and it began with
just somebody feeling belittled a
barbecue in in california i guess if if
we think of our own our own motivations
kind of on on an individual level
the way the way i the way i kind of
think of it is that
there is always some kind of status game
that i'm that i'm playing
in basically everything i do but there's
nothing i can do about it and so it's
actually kind of fine and so similar to
you know
why why why do i go to the gym well i
can pretend it's for health reasons but
but really everyone knows
what the real reason behind going to the
gym is yeah but that's that's not the
end of the world it's you know we don't
need to have fully pure altruistic
motives for the things we do to still
actually be good that's right it's like
men's health isn't really a health
magazine it's a sexy body magazine it's
an i want to look good naked magazine
you know and that's yeah that that's
right and and um
yeah
um i think the health version of that
wouldn't i don't think would celebrate
you can't you can't um
get away from it um it's it's in your
kind of body
it's in your brain you know as soon as
you're out um
in the world mixing with people
it's automatic you're judging them
they're judging you
the game is on hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye